hello everyone we're so glad you've
joined us for this live webinar
uncertainty choice and dopamine I am
soon family roots and I'll be moderating
today's session today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning let's get
started you can post questions to the
speaker during the presentation at any
time while they're fresh in your mind to
do so simply type them in the Q&A box
which will open when you click the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience any technical problem seeing
or hearing this presentation click on
the support button found at the bottom
of the top right of the presentation
window or report your problem by
clicking on the green Q&A button lower
left this is an educational webinar and
thus offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the see a button located at the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
and follow the process of obtaining your
credits I would like now to present
today's speaker speaker dr. Stan
florescu dr. Slifer esco is a professor
of psychology and member of the brain
research center at the university of
british columbia and a fellow of the
american college of
neuropsychopharmacology with over 90
peer-reviewed publications dr. flesh
tone specializes in research on
behavioral and neurophysiological
approaches to studying neural circuits
within the dopamine systems that
facilitate higher-order cognitive
functions such as cognitive flexibility
and cost-benefit decision-making he's
also interested in how dysfunction in
these circuits may relate to psychiatric
disease in 2010 dr. fresco was awarded
the American Psychological associations
early career award I will now turn it
over to dr. Flores fo for this
presentation
but thank you to lab roots for inviting
me to give this talk and for all you
joining us online thank you and for
those of you who are watching this on
demand later glad you could make it so
today I'd like to talk to you about some
what my colleagues and I have been
focusing on over the last 10 years or so
now looking at different neural circuits
within the dopamine system and how they
regulate certain aspects of reward
seeking within the context of risk
reward decision-making now life
routinely presents us with situations
where we have to choose between
different options that may yield us
different types of reward these rewards
can differ in terms of their subjective
value choosing between two things we
like we just happen to like one more
than the other the divers chocolate
versus her she needs craft beer versus
Budweiser what have you or they can
differ in terms of their objective value
basically more versus less reward and
all things being equal we tend to like
larger versus small rewards but the
decisions that will wrestle with that
give us pause or when these larger or
better rewards are associated with some
sort of costs that can diminish the
subjective value of objectively large
rewards and these costs can take a
variety of forms sometimes we may have
to work a little harder or wait a little
longer to obtain the things that we
prefer those will be the focus of my
talk sometimes these larger or better
rewards might be associated with some
sort of uncertainty or risk and we might
not always get rewarded for choosing a
certain course of action now these types
of decisions are particularly tricky
because here you have to do the wrong
term cost-benefit math and try to
ascertain well maybe I will always get
rewarded if I choose a certain course of
action but will it be more beneficial
for me in the long term if I play a
little more risky or a little more
conservative now studies on the neural
basis of risk reward decision-making
really find their roots in the mid 90s
with a pioneering work of Antonio
Damasio and anh tuan ma sha who devised
a novel task we now refer to as the Iowa
gambling task that was designed to tap
into
real world decision making in terms of
uncertainty rewards costs and
punishments now since those original
studies with the advent of new tasks use
of functional imaging and we've looking
at different patient populations we now
know the different aspects of risk
reward decision-making are mediated by
distributed neural circuits in the brain
that link different regions of the
frontal lobes the amygdala which resides
in the temporal lobes and the ventral
portion of the striatum also known as
the nucleus accumbens and one thing that
all these regions have in common in
addition to their own interconnectivity
is that they're all also connected with
a measle cortical limbic dopamine system
which suggests that dopamine may also
play a role in these functions so we've
known for nearly half a century that
dopamine plays some role in reward
although admittedly those of us who
study this molecule can always agree
exactly what its function is with
respect to dopamine neurons one thing we
know about these cells is that their
electrical activity is particularly
sensitive to situations involving the
presence or absence of expected or
unexpected rewards so if one records the
activity of dopamine neurons in an awake
behaving animal and they present them
with either rewards or cues associated
with those rewards 1 C is a
characteristic pattern of activity so if
we take an animal and present it with an
unexpected reward what that does is that
causes these dopamine neurons to fire a
brief phasic burst in activity to
increase their activity whereas if we
now start giving the adult some
information about those rewards present
a certain cue that reliably predicts
that the reward is coming eventually
these dopamine neurons actually start to
fire in response to that Q associated
with award but not necessarily the
reward itself on the other hand let's
say we present the animal with a cue
associated with that reward but then
when the animals expecting reward we
don't actually deliver it well in that
case we actually see a suppression and
dopamine neuron activity what we refer
to sometimes as a phasic dip and so
these increases in decreases
dopamine neuron activity associated with
expected or unexpected rewards or non
rewarded events I thought to encode what
are referred to as reward prediction
errors which may help an animal organize
its behavior and change its actions when
it's not getting what it expects to do
or promote continued action towards
getting these rewards now it seems that
dopamine neurons are also particularly
sensitive to situations involving reward
uncertainty because we can change the
scenario that I just described you here
now we can present the animal with a
variety of different cues some cues are
never associated with war there's a 0%
chance of getting a reward when that Q
is presented while another Q might
always be associated with Ward one
hundred percent chance and then there
may be some choose which only deliver
the rewards a certain portion of the
time 25 50 75 percent of the time and
these are seminal data from Wolfram
Schultz's group what they found in this
study is that the activity of dopamine
neurons in response to these different
cues was maximal in response to the cues
that presented the maximal amount of
reward uncertainty so that dopamine
neuron activity was much greater when
the animal was presented with the cue
that suggested he might get a reward
fifty percent of the time when you
compare that to cues that either always
predictable ward or that never predicted
reward so this suggests that the entire
dopamine system is particularly ticklish
when the organism is not quite sure
whether or not they're going to get a
reward now studies in humans have been
monumental on helping us identify some
of the different systems that may be
involved in using this information to
guide decision making but they don't
really allow us the experimental control
we need in order to understand the
mechanisms underlying the processes that
help guide our behavior when we have to
choose between different rewards of
different probabilities so we really
need to turn to the animal model to help
understand how these different systems
may interact and what their specific
roles may be in guiding risk for
decision-making
and so what by our group have been using
an assay that is referred to as a
probabilistic discounting task where we
get animals to choose between different
types of rewards varying in terms of
their magnitude and their relative
certainty so I'm going to spend a bit of
time discussing this asset because most
of the data i'll be showing you today
was using this basic type of task so
this task is conducted in an operant
chamber and the way this game works is
on any given trial we present the animal
with two options two levers if the
animal chooses what we call the small
certainly verb it always gets this
smaller one pellet reward so this is the
safe Canadian government savings bond
option you're not always going to get
that much of a return but he would
always guaranteed some return on your
investment now on the other hand on this
trial the animal might choose what we
call the large risky lever here the
animal may or may not get the larger
floor pellet reward and the probability
of the animal getting this reward
changes in a systematic manner over
blocks of trials within a daily session
and so the way we typically run this
game is at the start of the session the
odds of getting the reward are very high
either a hundred or fifty percent and
then as the session progresses the odds
get leaner and leader 250 25 and in 12.5
percent chance of the animal getting
that large reward and changes in these
reward probabilities are signaled by
blocks of forced choice trials before
every block of free choice trial so
first in every block would give the
animal we foresee animal to choose
either one of the believers and then
this way it can ascertain what the
relative probability of them obtaining
that reward is then we give them a
period of free choice trials we're both
libras are presented and now they have
to choose based on the information we
gave them which Lee when they prefer
which one they think is the better
option for them and if you take a look
at this graph here after about
20-something days of training I always
become relatively rational decision
makers on this town's choosing that
risky option more the reward
probabilities are high and then choosing
it less when the world probabilities are
lower
so in all the studies i'll be talking
about today animals were well trained on
this game so by the time we did our
neuro manipulations there were
experienced players and within any group
of animals we have some animals that are
tend to be more risky and some animals
that tend to play more conservative and
so we would use a within-subjects design
to see how when they alter different
nodes of dopamine circuitry how does
that alter the way they play the game on
that particular day and so in our
initial studies looking at how dopamine
might be involved we simply did systemic
treatments with different drugs that
interfere with dopamine transmission one
of the first things we found that is
that if we increase dopamine release by
giving a drug like amphetamines we get
this market increase in risky choice
animals were much slower to update the
changes in their decision bias and they
persisted in playing that risky option
even though the odds were getting poorer
and poorer on the other hand if we
reduced dopamine transmission by giving
a drug that blocks dopamine receptors
such as flippin fix all we see the
opposite change in behavior now animals
actually play much more conservative
they will risk averse they didn't like
choosing that large risky option and
would rather she was that smaller but
safer reward suggesting that dopamine
Thalia in the brain helps bias choice
towards use larger on certain rewards so
these data told us that don't mean
somewhere in the brain might be helping
modify these decision biases when
animals choose between risky versus
certain options so over the last few
years we will systematically targeted
different nodes within the dopamine
system to try to understand what their
functional contribution to these
problems are and in these experiments
before we started playing with dopamine
we just simply used reversible and
activations of different nucleic where
we could temporarily shut down neural
activity in these different regions to
kind of ascertain what role do they play
in guiding decisions what do they bring
to the table in terms of helping to
solve these types of problems
what I'm showing you here is a cartoon
showing some of the neural circuits that
we've looked at over the last few years
and showing their intrinsic connectivity
so you can see one nucleus the
basolateral amygdala which resides in
the temporal lobes and is important for
emotional processing it sends
projections to the nucleus accumbens the
basolateral liberal also shares
reciprocal connections with the medial
prefrontal cortex in the frontal lobes
and this cortical region also sends
projections to the striatum so I'm going
to summarize about six years worth of
data in the next 90 seconds or so just
to show you what our studies within
activations have shown what these
different regions contribute so what we
found is at one circuit linking the
basolateral amygdala to the nucleus
accumbens seems to play a key role in
biasing choice towards these larger
uncertain rewards because if we
inactivate either structure bilaterally
or if we disconnect communication
between these two structures we get a
market decrease in risky choice similar
to what we see when we block dopamine
receptors so this region is the one that
is promoting choice of these large
you're uncertain rewards for those of
you who play poker this is the part of
the brain that lights up when you have a
pair of kings in your hands and is
saying go all-in chase after that big
reward but these urges to play more
risky are tempered by the frontal lobes
and the this particular region of the
prefrontal cortex the medial region
analogous to area 32 of the anterior
cingulate in humans seems to play a more
cognitive role in helping a just
decision biases and keeping track of
actions and outcomes over multiple
trials to help ascertain what the
relative beneficial action is what are
the relative odds between these
different options and one of the reasons
I say that is because if we activate the
medial prefrontal cortex when the odds
are initially good at the start of the
session and then get poor as the session
progresses we see an increase in risky
choice and must keep choosing that risky
option even though it's not as
beneficial to do
however if we change the game a little
bit and have another group of animals
where the odds are initially poor at the
start of the session start at 12.5
percent and then get progressively
better in activation of the prefrontal
cortex actually causes the opposite
pattern of effect animals are slower to
update their decision biases and overall
choose less risky so what we think the
prefrontal cortex does in this situation
is it monitors changes in reward
contingencies that in turn helps the
animal change its behavior alter its
decision biases when things are changing
in its environment so one thing we were
really interested in seeing well how do
some of these circuits talk to each
other are they working independently of
each other or are they actually
cooperating sending information back and
forth to help refine these decision
biases and we were particularly
interested in understanding whether the
amygdala and the prefrontal cortex
interact directly to guide
decision-making now when we do a
bilateral and activation shutting down
both regions of a nucleus in in one
brain that will tell you that nucleus is
involved in a certain behavior but it
won't tell you who it's talking to what
other nuclei might be interacting with
but one way we can delineate the roots
of information transfer between brain
regions is by using a relatively
old-school traditional technique called
an asymmetrical or disconnection
inactivation procedure now the rationale
behind this procedure rests on two
assumptions first it assumes that for
any given behavior information may be
transmitted from one structure in this
example structure a to another structure
structure be on both sides of the brain
in parallel furthermore it assumes that
a unilateral and activation of any
structure by itself should have no great
effect on behavior because you will
still have a contralateral circuit
available on the other side of the brain
so what we do in this asymmetrical
disconnection procedure is on one side
of the brain we use a unilateral
inactivation of the output
structure and then we combine that with
a contralateral an activation of the
receiving structure downstream so what
this selectively does is it prevents
communication between this a and B
circuit on both sides of the brain so in
this example on the left side of the
brain structure be can't process
information from structure a because we
have that inactivation upstream on the
right side of the brain structure a is
intact but now structure be can't
process any information being
transmitted from structure a because
structure be has been inactivated so if
we need selective communication in this
circuit then this type of asymmetrical
disconnection should disrupt behavior
but let's say that structure area is not
talking to structure beam let's say it
struck talking to another structure say
structure seat well in this case we
would not expect a big effect on
behavior because we would still have a
free circuit on one side of the brain so
we use this procedure to ascertain
whether the amygdala and the prefrontal
cortex form a functional circuit to help
guide decision-making and so as you can
see here the data when we just infuse
saline as a control procedure animals
showed rational pattern of
decision-making choosing the larger
reward more when the odds were good and
choosing it less when the odds were bad
now when we conducted an ipsilateral
inactivation so when we disconnected
communication between the amygdala and
the prefrontal cortex only on one side
of the brain we got no change in
behavior but it's when we disconnected
communication on both sides of the brain
between these structures while we saw
profound change now to be quite honest
we weren't sure what was going to happen
here because as you may recall when we
bilaterally in activated either
structure either the amygdala or the
prefrontal cortex we actually got
opposing effects on behavior when we
inactivated the prefrontal cortex
animals chose more risky and we're
slower to update their decision biases
where's when we inactivated the amid
analysts played more conservative so we
weren't sure if a disconnection might
just cancel both of these effects out or
we might get a different pattern of
behavior well it turns out when we
selectively disrupt prefrontal amygdala
communications we get a prefrontal like
phenotype again animals were more risky
they were slower to update their
behavior that kept choosing that risky
option even though the odds were getting
poorer and poorer over the course of the
session suggesting that these two
regions are communicating to help refine
decision bias and modify action
selection when there are changes and
reward contingencies now one thing we do
in these types of studies is we do a
more fine detailed analysis of the
behavior try to understand well why
exactly our animals playing more or less
risky and so we do a choice by choice
analysis to see well are they playing
more risky because maybe they like the
rewards better so we can look at wind
stay behavior looking at the probability
of them choosing the risky option after
playing risky on the previous trial in
winning and in this case that process
didn't seem to be effective instead the
reason the animals seem to be playing
more risky is that they were less
sensitive to losses we saw a decrease in
what we term their lose shift behavior
so normally what an animal plays risky
and losses on a trial doesn't get that
reward we've seen them shift to the more
conservative option on the next trial
about thirty to forty percent of the
time when we prevented the illegal and
the prefrontal cortex from talking to
each other we saw a market decrease in
this lose shift behavior as if the
animals either were unaware or didn't
care that they were losing more as a
session progresses so they kept playing
risky now as I told you this pathway is
reciprocally connected and even though I
don't have time to go into the details
of the data we have done some follow-up
experiments where we have identified
that this effect where we see a
disruption in choice behavior when we
disconnect the prefrontal cortex and
amygdala is actually mediated
a descending pathway where the
prefrontal cortex it seems to it seems
to exert top-down control over the
amygdala so these signals seem to
originate in the frontal lobes and an
ascender mediating influence over cares
behavior that is normally driven by
amygdala ventral striatum circuits so
when we take these data and kind of
integrate it into a kind of model
circuit diagram that we are building to
help understand how these different
regions in Iraq to guide behavior but
when the animal is choosing between
different options we have one circuit
this subcortical more visceral circuit
linking the amygdala and the ventral
striatum that is biasing choice towards
these larger uncertain rewards is it too
safe rewind seat go after that big
reward but these urges are tempered by
the frontal lobes whereas they used
exert top-down control over the niccola
and the prefrontal lobes keep track of
actions and outcomes over time ascertain
that a this particular course of action
is not yielding us as much reward as it
used to perhaps we should change our
strategy perhaps we should maybe play a
little more conservative and then it
uses its influence to suppress or
mediate these urges to kiss after those
big rewards driven by these subcortical
circuits and so this is a common thing
we see an emotional regulation as well
as we have these subcortical systems
that are driving emotional responses but
they are modified and tempered by
different regions of the frontal lobe so
now that we had an idea of some of the
key hardware that the brain uses in
terms of solving these problems we were
interested in seeing some of the
software that let being involved in
these processes namely how Delta me may
play a role and in these studies what we
did was simple straightforward
psychopharmacological studies where we
would administer small volumes of drugs
that interfere with dopamine
transmission in our two key terminal
regions here the medial prefrontal
cortex and the nucleus accumbens
now in one study we targeted these mezzo
accumbens pathway and the results here
were relatively straightforward one
thing I can tell you is that when we
targeted different dopamine receptor
subtypes so there are two key receptor
subtypes we were interesting the
dopamine d2 receptor and the d1 receptor
whereas when we blocked d2 receptors in
the accumbens we saw no real change in
choice behavior now these doses were
behaviorally active animals were slower
to make choices they move dress in the
chamber but disrupting d2 receptor
transmission didn't seem to affect their
general pattern of choice behavior
instead the big player in the accumbens
seem to be the d1 receptor because when
we block these receptors we saw a
decrease in risky choice animals chose
that risky option much less and in this
instance the reason they were playing
more conservative the reason they were
more risk-averse was this manipulation
caused an increased sensitivity to
losses so when they played risky and
they lost they were now more likely to
switch to the conservative option on the
next trial in opposition to what we saw
when we disrupted prefrontal amygdala
circuitry so these data suggest that
within the ventral striatum for the
nucleus accumbens the d1 receptor plays
a key role in litigating sensitivity to
losses and promoting case towards these
larger uncertain rewards now and the
prefrontal cortex the story was a little
bit more complicated here we also
targeted these two key dopamine receptor
subtypes and when we blocked opening to
d2 receptors here we saw an increase in
risky choice very similar to what we see
when we in activate the prefrontal
cortex and so when we took these
receptors out of the equation when
delton was not allowed to signal through
these receptors animals again persisted
in choosing that risky option even
though the odds were changing so we
interpret these data to mean that one
function of dopamine d2 receptors in the
frontal lobes
may facilitate exploration of different
options when rewards changes because
when we enacted it or we block these
receptors animals are slower to start
exploring new options when the reward
probabilities decrease over time now
what we were particularly taken back was
when we blocked Oakland d 1 receptors we
actually saw the opposite changing
behavior from when we block d 2
receptors animals again were more
risk-averse similar what we saw when we
block these receptors new comments and
again they were more sensitive to losses
if they played risky and they lost after
we bought d 1 receptors they are more
likely to switch to that conservative
options so we interpret this to mean
that D 1 receptors are playing a
distinct yet complementary role to what
d 2 receptors are doing in the
prefrontal cortex and these receptors
may facilitate exploitation of currently
favorable circumstances so the idea is
when the animal plays risky and loses
activity at d1 receptor sites may help
bridge the gap between rewarded and non
rewarded actions as if to facilitate the
ability of the system to say hey you
didn't win on this particular trial but
keep at it because it may be more
profitable in the long term don't be so
disgruntled because you didn't win on
this trial it might be better for you to
keep at this risky option so as a
psychologist we loved associations we
love it when two brain systems are
showing opposite changes in behavior but
this is a weird one when you think about
because the brain doesn't release a d1
or d2 receptor agonist it releases
dopamine which would be expected to
stimulate both receptors so how does the
same neurotransmitter system working in
this same brain region mediate different
patterns of behavior seemingly opposite
patterns of behavior just by working on
different receptors so for that we wear
eyes were kind of reopened to the IP ax
and some recent studies that came out in
2012
showed that there actually appeared to
be separate populations of projection
neurons within the prefrontal cortex
that only expressed d1 or only express
d2 receptors so we have what appears to
be separate circuits that are only
modulated by one receptor or the other
and so this may be how dopamine may be
able to exert differential effects when
we take one receptor out of the equation
or the other by working on separate
micro circuits now we follow these
experiments up with some other studies
trying to see whether these different
circuits may have different projection
targets and I won't have time to show
you today to today but what it looks to
be going on is that we may have one
circuit of a remember of prefrontal
neurons that contain d2 receptors that
project to the amygdala that mediate one
part of the choice that mediate
exploration of new options that
facilitate changes in decision biases
whereas another circuit made up of
neurons that contain primarily d 1
receptors may be interacting with a
separate subcortical nucleus in this
case the ventral striatum to promote
exploitation of currently favorable
circumstances so those of us who study
dopamine and are hoping to find a grand
unified theory of its function well
these data suggest that our task is a
little bit harder because even though
we're looking at just one single brain
region it seems that within a particular
brain region dopamine may be doing
different things and facilitating
different cognitive operations and
patterns of behavior by working on
distinct sub circuits or ensembles of
neurons and these neurons can differ in
terms of the specific dopamine receptors
that they express and their particular
projection targets so as we continue to
try to understand how a dopamine may be
involved in cognition and behavior we're
going to have to account for the fact
that we have separate groups of cells
even within one particular brain region
that may be promoting quite different
patterns of behavior
so these studies showed us that dopeman
clearly played an important role in
facilitating modifications and decision
biases and promoting choice a larger
risk your rewards we were particularly
interested in seeing what how the
changes in dopamine release relate to
changes in the animal's behavior the
dopamine levels just go up and stay up
or are there of other dynamic
fluctuations in dopamine transmission
before we get to those studies I just
want to integrate these dopamine data
here with this emerging circuit that
we're talking so we have our prefrontal
amygdala striatal circuits and within
this circuit dopamine seems to be doing
different things in different brain
regions and acting on different dopamine
receptors d 1 receptors in both the
prefrontal cortex and the nucleus
accumbens seem to reduce the sensitivity
to non reward actions and promote and
maintain choice biases so it helps an
organism keep that eye on the prize
maybe you didn't win this time but keep
at it because it might be more
profitable in the long term whereas d2
receptors in the prefrontal cortex seem
to facilitate changes and decision
biases and promote exploration of new
options and within the prefrontal cortex
as I said d1 and d2 receptors may
mediate different aspects of reward
seeking by acting on dis sick distinct
ensembles of prefrontal projection
neurons that may have distinct
subcortical projection targets so how do
dopamine levels change when animals are
engaging in these behaviors well to do
this we collaborate with my former PhD
supervisor Tony Phillips and his
long-term research associate solely on
on and we used in vivo microdialysis
which permitted us to look at
fluctuations in tonic dopamine levels in
these different terminal regions while
animals were actually performing and
playing the game and these experiments
animals were again well trained on the
task and a lot of test day we would
implant them with micro diocese probes
in either the prefrontal cortex or the
nucleus accumbens
so we could see how dope Nemo was
changed there were different phases of
the task and in this task we were able
to use a sampling interval of seven
minutes why do I bring that up well this
relatively short sampling interval would
allow us to look at changes in dopamine
release during the forced choice portion
of each block so when animals were only
presented with one Leifer so didn't
actually have to make a decision just
how to respond on whatever option we
gave them and then compare that to
changes in dopamine release during the
free choice portions of the sessions
where they actually had to make a choice
and in these experiments we had separate
groups of animals on the train were the
odds initially we're good to start of
the session and then got poor change
from a hundred percent to 12.5 percent
and our groups of animals where the odds
were de sheep or at the start of the
session and then that better started at
12.5 percent and progressively increased
now we needed a key control experiment
in these tasks because anyone who knows
anything about dopamine is just the
damier consumption of shrewd is enough
to turn this system on so if we see
changes in dopamine release when rats
are engaged in decision-making we needed
to ascertain well how much of this
signal is driven by them actually having
to make decisions and evaluations versus
the mere consumption of food so in these
experiments we included a key yoked food
control experiment animals in these
groups they didn't have to press any
Lieber's they don't have to make any
decisions what happened with them is on
any given trial Every 40 seconds the
house lights came on and they would
receive either four pallets one pellet
or zero pellets and the scheduling and
amount of rewards they received during
these sessions were matched identically
to animals that had actually performed
the task so here we could control for
the amount and the scheduling of food
that they received so in these groups
animals were just basically receiving
food for free do
have to work for their dinner they would
just get this food but they got it on
the exact same schedule as an animal
that actually had to work for its supper
and have to make decisions in terms of
how having to maximize its rewards so if
you all start with what we saw in the
prefrontal cortex and one thing I can
tell you is that when we looked at
animals where the odds went from good to
bad and compare that when the odds went
from bad to good we saw mirror image
profiles of each other and we were able
to combine the data and when we plot
these data in terms of changes in
prefrontal dopamine release as a
function of reward probability you can
see in these green circles here that
dopamine levels were higher when the
probability of obtaining that larger
reward was higher and then they were
lower when the odds of getting these
four pallets were lower so one of the
first things we noticed about this
change in the dopamine signal is that it
didn't really map on very well to
changes in the animal's behavior what
these white circles are showing you here
is how often animals actually chose the
large risky option over the course of
the session and as you can see the
change in choice behavior didn't really
mirror the change in the dopamine signal
instead what it looked like was the
change in prefrontal dopamine levels and
the signals from the dopamine system
that the frontal lobes are receiving
mapped on very well to changes in how
much food how much reward the animal was
receiving over time what these triangles
are showing you is the relative amount
of reward pellets animals received over
the session and as you can see here the
slope of the change in the amount of
food they received looking in that curve
was practically identical to changes in
the amount of dopamine that would being
released over these comparable sessions
and what's more when we looked at the
data from our animals in the yoked group
animals that didn't press any levers
that didn't make any decisions and
simply got the same amount of food in
the same pattern of food
for free we saw a near-identical profile
again dopamine levels were higher when
they were getting more food and then
lower when they were getting less food
so what this suggests to us that
fluctuations in prefrontal dopamine
levels seem to be keeping track of how
much reward animals are receiving over
time serving the sort of a reward
running rate meter and if you think
about what the prefrontal cortex might
be doing in these types of situations
keeping track of actions and outcomes
over time to help modify behavior the
system would need some sort of
information to kind of update over a
longer term period of how are we doing
in terms of our profits are we getting
more or less reward over time to help
modify behavior these data suggest that
changes in dopamine transmission in the
frontal lobes maybe one such input to
this region that the prefrontal cortex
uses to help adjust behavior in the
accumbens the story was a little bit
more complicated we again saw that
dopamine levels were higher when reward
probabilities were higher and then lower
when the odds of getting those rewards
were less but the profile looked quite
different to what we saw in the
prefrontal cortex the first thing we
notice here was changes and accumbens
dopamine levels mapped on almost
perfectly the changes in the animal's
behavior so the rate of change in
dopamine release over the course of the
session was pretty much the same as the
rate and change of how often the animal
chose those risky options now the other
thing I'd like to point out here is you
see in this profile looking at the green
circles we see this sawtooth profile
when dopamine levels are lower and then
they go up a bit then the lower are
going up a bit again with these
oscillations in dopamine represent our
changes in dopamine release during the
forced choice portions of each blog
compared to the fruit choice portions
where the animals actually have to make
a decision and as it turns out when the
animals actually have to choose dopamine
levels are just a little bit higher then
when the animals simply have to make
response don't have any choice in the
matter and just have to press a single
lever so the system seems to turn our
wounded more when the animals actions
and their choices have a direct outcome
of what they might be receiving now in
comparison changes in dopamine release
in the accumbens did not map on very
well to changes in the amount of root
word they received over time as I'm
showing you in these red triangles here
but we still conducted our guilt food
control experiment here we saw an
interesting profile what these squares
are showing you here is changes in
dopamine release and animals that got
the exact same amount of reward and the
same pattern of rewards as animals have
played the task and what I want you to
notice here is that when at these posts
of the sessions don't be levels weren't
comparable but then the curves separate
at this point here what is special about
that point there is that these are the
portions of the task where the animals
have to make a choice and there is on
some uncertainty about the action they
may not get rewarded for those choices
in the early part of the session here
they're either always guaranteed to get
some reward either a larger or smaller
board or have no choice in the matter
but as soon as we have the situations
where now the animals have to choose and
they might not get a reward when they
chose a certain action dopamine levels
were higher then we compare that to
animals that just got this food for free
so the system seems to be more engaged
when the animal has to make a choice and
the animal is not entirely sure whether
or not their choices might lead them to
rewards so what this suggests to us is
that changes in these slower tonic
levels of extra synoptic dopamine in the
ventral striatum may be integrating a
variety of different signals and provide
a long-term accounting of multiple types
of information including the animals
choice behavior what it's doing the
relative amount of uncertainty
associated with those choices as
as changes in the amount of reward
they're receiving over time so
fluctuations in these slower tonic
dopamine levels in the accumbens seem to
be integrating multiple types of
information so when we look at doping
transmission within the strydom they are
again these slower changing levels of
dopamine that fluctuate over longer
periods many minutes but there are also
these faster phasic signals I described
to you at the beginning that are
mediated by burst firing of dopamine
neurons now if you want to look at
dopamine release that is me needed by
these bursting events of dopamine
neurons other investigators have used
more rapid measuring techniques that
have a higher temperance uh Chazz in
vivo voltammetry and there has been a
fair amount of excellent work done by a
number of investigators using these
faster techniques to measure rapid
changes in dopamine release within the
accumbens when animals were engaged in
cost-benefit decision-making so the data
I'm showing you here our data from one
of my good friends Regina Corelli in her
group and here they recorded rapid
changes in dopamine release in the
nucleus accumbens when animals were
performing a very similar game to what I
described to you here where they were
accusing between a larger uncertain and
smaller certain rewards and two things
they noticed here is that before the
animal would make a choice a few seconds
before the animal would have to choose
between the options or make a response
we would see phasic increase in doping
release that you can see on the time
scale here lasts a few seconds rather
than changes over minutes that we were
monitoring with microdialysis and the
magnitude of this phasic increased prior
the choice was related to whether or not
the animal was permitted to choose its
more preferred option so dopamine levels
were higher when the animals were either
forced to choose their more preferred
option or had the choice between their
preferred and less preferred option when
they compared the magnitude of release
what animals were forced to choose the
option they didn't like as much
and then after the animal made a choice
dopamine levels increased again in a
rapid and phasic manner and in this
instance the magnitude of the change in
dopamine release seemed to encode the
outcomes of those choices so of animals
played risky and the one get that larger
reward they saw a large increase in
dopamine release if they chose the
smaller certain option they saw a
comparably smaller increase in dopamine
release and almost times where they
played risky and they lost they actually
saw a decrease in dopamine release very
similar to what I described to you in
the beginning or how dope neon seemed to
encode reward prediction errors showing
a larger increase when they get an
unexpected reward and showing a decrease
when they don't receive any reward so we
were interested in seeing how light
these rapid phasic signals in dopamine
release regulate choice behavior and
action selection now we've done our
pharmacological experiments where we
would block dopamine receptors but but
those don't really tell you what these
rapid signals are when you go in with an
antagonist and block dopamine receptors
your blunting all types of signals most
these rapid phasic signals and these
slower changing atomic signals for the
int for an hour or two so it doesn't
really parse out what specific
information these basic signals are so
we needed a way to use a temporary
precise mechanism to suppress these
phasic signals it turns out that nature
has provided us with a neural circuit
that exerts inhibitory control over the
dopamine system in that circuit involves
a nucleus referred to as a lateral
habenula this is an evolutionary very
old nucleus we see this and all sorts of
vertebrate species and one reason
there's been a lot of interest in this
nucleus is that it seems to have a
pronounced inhibitory effect over the
firing of dopamine neurons because if
you stimulate the lateral habenula that
causes a market suppression in dopamine
neuron activity very similar to phasic
dips and activity that are observed when
an animal doesn't receive an expected
war now recordings from lateral habenula
neurons and awake behaving animals have
shown it well these neurons they're the
kind of like the opposite of dopamine
neurons I like to call them dopamine
neurons from the evil parallel universe
what I mean by that is they actually
fire more when something bad happens
like the animal doesn't get an expect
rewards and they actually suppress their
activity when something good happens
like they get a reward and the number of
studies over the last ten years or so
have identified that the ability of the
habenula to suppress dopamine neuron
activity is mediated by a Dyson optic
circuit where we have excitatory
projections from the habenula the then
target a relatively newly discovered
nucleus in the back of the brain called
the rostrum medial tegmental nucleus or
the our MTG and turn the our MTG sends a
dense inhibitory gabaergic input to
definitely neurons in the VTA so by
activating the habenula we can suppress
dopamine neuron activity in the VTA in a
very temporary specific manner so we
used discrete electrical stimulation of
either the habenula or the BTA itself to
modify and overwrite these different
phasic signals that are associated with
decision-making and to ask do these
outcome related in pre choice phasic
signals modify action selection during
decision-making so in one experiment we
have a situation that were well where we
had animals well-trained in a task and
sometimes they would choose that risky
option and they would not get a reward
that's our life works sometimes well
what we know from previous studies that
is in these situations whether if she
was risky and lose that causes a
suppression in dopamine neuron activity
aphasic tip so under these conditions
only when animals chose risky and lost
we would give a brief half a second
stimulation to the dopamine neurons in
the ventral tegmental area the idea here
is now we are overriding these phasic
dips actually causing a phasing burst
tricking the system potentially into
thinking it may have got rewarded when
actually didn't
and what we saw in this situation is
that only when we stimulated the BTA
after a loss animals started choosing
more risky they started to behave as if
that risky option was paying off much
more than it actually was so enlarging
their behavior in another direction just
by overriding these signals that
occurred when they are all played risky
and lost now on the other hand sometimes
we have a situation where the animal
would choose that risky option and win
get that larger reward what we know is
happening here in terms of doping
transmission is that that causes a brief
phasic burst and dopamine neuron
activities near and start to fire for a
brief period of time so what we did in
this situation is every time the animal
played risky and one got that larger
reward while the animal was receiving
that reward we would give a few brief
pulses to the lateral habenula which as
we know will suppress dopamine neuron
activity and suppress these phasic
bursts so here we are trying to
overwrite these signals and again trick
the system into thinking that maybe
didn't get the reward that it thought it
did and under these conditions we saw
the opposite of what we saw when we
stimulated the VTA animals chose the
risky option less started behaving as if
that risky option was not paying off as
much they were not receiving this large
reward even though they were tasting the
food consuming the food their behavior
when we suppress these phasic first that
occurred with receiving the award seemed
to suggest that they were not
registering those wins and they just
their behavior thinking hey this is not
paying off as much now to be perfectly
honest we were having some fun with
these experiments what I was because I
wasn't actually conducting the
experiments but it was like we could
remote control the animals to a certain
degree by stimulating at a certain time
we could bias their behavior one way or
the other so we did another experiment
well what happens when we stimulate the
habenula and suppress these phasic
increases in belton
when the animal chooses that small
certain option when it goes for that
safe government savings bond so now we
are simulating a crash in the bond
market so every time we suppress
dopamine activity when the animal chose
that small reward and got that large a
small reward we again saw a change in
behavior here it increased risky choice
animals behaved as if well this small
option is not paying off anymore now it
may be that these effects were due to
just some aversive responsibilities like
being stimulated in the head manual and
so they are just choosing the other
lever to avoid stimulation well we don't
think that's the case because when we do
a key control experiment where animals
are just choosing a very simple type of
decision a large reward versus small
reward both delivered at one hundred
percent certainty and if we stimulated
the habenula every time they got the
large reward in this simple situation
there was no change in behavior so it's
not like they didn't like getting
stimulated but when we still related in
situations involving uncertainty that's
when we got changes in behavior so what
these outcome related phasic bursts and
dips seem to be doing is providing
short-term information about recently
rewarded and non rewarded actions to
influence subsequent choice behave now
what about those pre choice signals
these increases in dopamine release that
occur where before the animal has to
make a choice well we know right before
they need to make a choice we get this
large increase in dopamine release so
what we did in another group of animals
is every time they were about to make a
choice we again similar the habenula and
suppressed that preachers increase what
happened about one thing that happened
was that it reduced the incentive
salience of the leavers what I mean by
that is there one out a little slower to
make a choice they didn't seem as
invigorating to go after those leavers
and are more likely to miss out on
trials and in terms of their choice
behavior when we looked at the entire
group this tended to reduce choice of
that large risky option but when we
trolled some individual differences in
our group we found that
some animals tend to just always look
that risky option irrespective of the
odds they kept choosing that risky
option whether the odds were good or bad
and in these situations when we suppress
these preachers phasic signals it
uniformly reduced their preference for
that large reward other rats on the
other hand played more rationing shows
the risky option more when the odds were
good shows it less when the odds are bad
here we saw that suppression of preacher
signals tended to disrupt their
preference for their more preferred
options so they kills the risky option
less when they preferred that option and
they chose it slightly more when they
preferred the small safe options so we
interpret these data to mean that these
increases in dopamine release prior to a
choice seem to promote actions directed
towards more preferred rewards now
dopamine doesn't seem to be involved in
actually making the preference in
deciding what's the better option this
is mediated by these other circuits I've
been talking about the frontal lobes the
amygdala what have you and dopamine
helps ensure that once a certain bias
has been established that the animal's
behavior is directed towards what is
being the better option now lastly I
want to finish up with some studies
looking at the involvement of the
lateral habenula itself because while
stimulation has been a useful tool for
manipulating phasic signals we wanted to
see what happens when we remove this
node out of the circuit so for those of
you who aren't familiar with the anatomy
I'm showing you here that the habenula
is a relatively tiny nucleus and it's
somewhat difficult to hit surgically so
my student who worked on this Collin
stopper he initially did a set of
experiments and he came to my office
after he completed and he said Stan
there was no effect on choice and I said
well let's check the histology turns out
there were a bunch of love replacements
in the dorsal hippocampus right above
the Havana so we don't need that part of
the brain to guide decision-making I
said try again came back a few months
later there's still no effects now and I
looked at the histology now we're
getting closer to our target but still
no effect try again another experiment
now he overshot now he was below the
habeo
no effect on behavior and we were
getting a little frustrated at this
point because what does it take to hit
this nucleus now finally after about a
year of trying my student was able to
amass enough placements within the
target nucleus and what did we see well
rather simple mindedly we thought that
if the have any Allah is telling you
what's bad in the environment then if we
will activate this nucleus we might have
a situation where animals just don't
recognize they're losing and they keep
choosing more risky but we saw something
much more profound when we inactivated
this new place we completely abolished
any decision bias they had they went
from choosing rationally choosing
risking more when the odds are good and
choosing less when the odds were bad too
random and haphazard patterns of choice
so that as a group they were choosing
both options roughly fifty percent of
the time behaving as if they had no idea
which was the better option and so they
were choosing completely random now
whenever you see in effect this magnet
of this magnitude well maybe they're
just blind maybe they don't know the
difference between their left paw in the
right part doesn't seem to be the case
because if we give them a simple
decision big reward smogon would both
delivered with a hundred percent
certainty and wien activate the habenula
there was no choice when the animals
have to choose between two awards that
differ only in their objective value big
versus small the habenula doesn't seem
to be involved but as soon as there is
some sort of cost where the animal has a
subjective preference it has to use the
guide its behavior the habenula seems to
play a fundamental role in expressing
subjective choice biases so when we
integrate these last bits of information
on model seeing that these slower
changing Tomic dopamine levels in the
prefrontal cortex and the accumbens seem
to have a long-term accounting of choice
and reward history prefrontal cortex
opening tracks changes in reward rates
over time whereas a comments that mean
the tonic signal integrates information
about the amount of reward received the
relative amount of risk and choice in
contrast these phasic rapid signals seem
to play a short
time accounting conveying short-term
information about the outcomes of
choices and then promoting actions
directed towards more preferred rewards
and within this entire circuit de la
rioja beg no seems to be a key link spin
around with these cortical striatal
limbic systems and the dopamine systems
to work in a coordinated manner because
when we suppress activity in this new
bliss it's throws the entire system and
disarray animals don't know what the
better option is in behave random
suggesting that this evolutionary old
nucleus plays a key role in enabling
expression of subjective choice
preferences with that I would like to
thank this great students I've had over
the years I've had a number of talented
hard-working as you can see here
photogenic students those who have shown
in the pictures here or those who
contribute directly to the experiments
along with a number of other students
I've had over the years and this is a
recent shot of my wonderful lab here and
I'd like to thank you all for joining
the online now I will now take any
questions well thank you dr. falasca for
your fantastic presentation that was
really really informative and I learned
so much so as a quick reminder for
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box which
can be found in the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your presentation
window will answer as many questions as
we have time for today so the first
question while we're waiting for
audience members to formulate their
questions if I could could you ask if I
could ask question could you comment on
the how this function in the domain
circuits relate to psychiatric disorders
that we see in human that affect human
behaviors psychiatric disorders that
that seemed to be associated with
dysfunctions in the dopamine system and
so one thing that our data showed that
and we are building on a vast literature
people who looked at this type of work
is that dopamine activity seems to
signal important events in the
environment and may increase the
likelihood of an organism engaging in
similar behaviors that lead to this
increase in dopamine and so if we have a
situation where we have excessive
increases in dopamine release like we
might see in drug addiction or in
schizophrenia this aberrant increase in
dopamine transmission may the example of
addiction may promote individuals to
continue to engage in drug-seeking
behavior in response to cues or what
happened and allow them to or kind of
make it harder for them to stop engaging
these types of drugs with respect to
schizophrenia we know that dopamine
seems to be related to the delusions of
the psychotic symptoms and excessive
increases in dopamine activity may be
involved in kind of having an aberrant
salience attribution where individuals
pay more attention to the seemingly
innocuous stimuli and that may
contribute to that delusions on the
flipside reductions in dopamine
transmissions may be related to certain
aspects of depression where individuals
might not have the energy the motivation
to go after good things in life which is
a key symptom associated with depression
great thank you for that um so we're
running a little bit short on time so i
would like to run once again thank you
for such a fantastic presentation do you
have any final comments for us on how
these neural circuits affect human
behavior and decision making for with
these
who types explain what I think you know
we need to understand we love to kind of
black box different brain structures
this brain region does that this brain
region is that but I really think as we
continue with behavioral neuroscience
and understanding how the brain controls
behavior we have to think of it in terms
of dynamic interactions between
different systems and one brain region
they contribute in a variety of
different matters to control behavior
depending on the different inputs and
outputs it's connecting with and if we
want to understand what's going on it
when the brain doesn't work well in
psychiatric disorders I think we need to
found a firm foundation and seeing how
the brain normally works to solves
problems that gives us greater insight
into euro dysfunction that was fantastic
I'd like to once again thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting participation um we
have some questions that we didn't have
time for today but we will try to
address those by dr. fresco via the
information that you provided at the
time of registration this webcast and be
viewed on demand through September 2016
library to alert you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share the email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye